مرحله جديده دخلتها التحقيقات الجنائيه
التي يواجهها الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب
تحتمل تاويلات كثيره على الاقل من جانبه
فبعد ثلاثه ايام على تقديم ترامب ترشيحه
للسباق الرئاسيه المقبل عين جاكسونس
المدعي العام السابق لجرائم الحرب مستشارا
خاصا جديدا للاشراف على التحقيقات بكيفيه
التعامل الرئيس السابق مع الوثائق السريه
ودوره المزعوم في الهجوم على مبنى
الكابيتل
ان ترشحترام
لاداره التحقيق والادعاء بشكل مستقله
مضيفا ان ذلك ما تقتضيه المصلحه العامه في
حالات استثنائيه كهذه لمنح جمهور الثقه
بالتحقيق
التعيين وصفه رئيس السابق بوصمه عار واسوء
تاسيس للعداله في التاريخ الامريكيه مرجعا
السبب الرئيسي للخطوه الى تقدمه بكل
استطلاعات الراي كمرشحا للرئاسه وتمسك
بعدم المشاركه بالتحقيق نافيا ارتكابه اي
مخالفه بالاصل
وصنف خطوه وزاره العدل في خانه الاستغلال
الرهيب للسلطه وفق تعبيره
اجراء التحقيقات المطلوبه واي محاكمه قد
تنجم عنها بشكل مستقله مع العلم بانه من
سيقرر امكانيه مواجهه ترامب لتوها من
جنائيه وبالتالي عرق للطرقه من البيت
الابيض
وبحسب مراقبين فان تكلفه مستشار خاص يضمن
الحياده ويبعد بيضا عن اي شبهات بدورا
يعرقل نجاحها خصمه المحتمل في الانتخابات
المقبله
[تصفيق]